[Music]
funerals in Syria haven't stopped during
the past 12 years of war this is one of
the latest after a drone attack on a
government Military Academy coffins are
taken to the final resting
places these are the last moments
recorded on camera of a graduation
ceremony at the
Academy then a drawn attack turns the
celebration into a blood bath
we attended the ceremony till the end
and then we went to greet our relatives
then it was that massive sound I woke up
here as we Stood Beside my brother there
was a huge explosion people were around
us on the ground I don't know what
happened to my brother while no one
claimed responsibility for the attack
the Syrian military blamed what it calls
armed terrorist organizations supported
by known International
parties this is obviously a real coup
for whoever's carried it out because it
is at a military base it's Cadets it's
targeted and uh it's using advanced
technology immediately after the attack
government forces bombarded Rebel held
idlib in Northern Syria several people
are reported to have been killed and
others
injured the day before Syria State tv
CED a Russian commander in Syria
warning of possible attacks on Russian
or Syrian
positions according to the deputy head
of the Russian Center for reconciliation
of Waring parties viim kulit terrorists
are planning to carry out a series of
attacks on the locations of the Russian
military and the Syrian
government who carried out the attack on
the military academy in hums is on clear
but it's exposed how the 12year war is
far from over and that the way they are
fighting is Shifting Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer